there were just days left in the school
year here in clark county same thing
tomorrow is the last day safety top of
mind for everyone madison kimbrough
joining us live in studio now with their
reaction
acts of violence have been surfacing for
months now with the clark county school
district and with this most recent
shooting in texas it's very clear that
this violent behavior among our youth is
nationwide
that is everyone's fear that to wake up
to a local tragedy like that where your
kids are in school
that's the worst nightmare edward holmes
sharing his thoughts on the horrific
aftermath of tuesday's shooting at a
texas elementary school it's disturbing
i think children
today even
you know at home they're
a little bit on edge and it seems
that the younger generation is more
violent here locally the clark county
school district having more than 5 300
reports of violence on school grounds
along with 26 illegal shootings this
school year alone the school district
releasing this statement stating quote
ccsd continues to review assess and
address the security of our schools to
provide a conducive learning environment
for students and a positive work
environment for our staff clark county
education association president marie
nicest says with school ending wednesday
there's still so much work to be done to
ensure that next year's school year is
not a repeat of this past year what
occurred in texas today reminds us of
how quickly something can happen and how
tragic it can turn so there are things
that got put into place but are they
enough we don't have enough personnel on
our campuses so i think it's very
important that the dr jarrah's
things that he wants to implement as far
as safety are continuing to be focused
on
and according to ccsdpd
officers will be out in full force
tomorrow with metro north las vegas pd
and henderson pd making their presence
known